I reject nation catching up on stranger
things while feeling under the weather
I'm about to watch chapter 7 the lost
sister I'm assuming this is about 11
only things been spoiled for me is that
there's one episode entirely dedicated
to 11 that people are not seemingly
responding all too positively to I have
no idea what the details are about based
off the title I would assume that this
is the other girl that was in Rainbow
Room and the girl who's at the beginning
of the series so yeah chapter 7 7-eleven
she developed a real personality along
the way you know I I kind of like this
cuz it feels just like a different 80s
movie oh yeah just feels like another
type of eighties movie although it is
very totally different yeah you have
[Music]
nothing actor who got the sad handy J
and monster
it feels like you're next
[Music]
is still shot cool yeah I can see people
have initiatives this is a hottie looks
cool though does feel like a setup for
something else
tragedy girls
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I like seed this side of 11 I'm
kinda I like it I like it I just know
he's like so
I'll take you through damn no one she is
so good at like any stuff with using her
powers like this side of a lemon
this is fascinating
killing his kids he's a vulture oh [ __ ]
oh no oh okay yeah that makes a
difference don't do it
now she ain't gonna do it
[Music]
we gotta go okay they called the cops
[Music]
tension is big snap diggity can't you
just make them all like turn it
consistently invisible to make this
easier
eleven just wants a place to belong to
now she's gonna miss her friends she's
gonna want to go home oh yeah you got to
go back
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's what I would say you should
do it's like the invisible thing a lot
easy but I guess you have to stay
perfectly still or something I don't
know no that's why you should you should
hang out with gangsters kids you're
watching the strange of things don't
hang out with gangsters take our hair
got shot
Wow
[Music]
my friends my friends are in danger this
isn't awkward so we gotta go right now
your mother send you live for a reason
remember you belong together there's
nothing for you back there they cannot
save EJ no I can it's close
go read Nye with them kiss Mike make our
Mike he deserves it because Mike
[Music]
damn they got they got that bullet for a
fan on
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay either two things are gonna happen
she's gonna appear in stranger things
season three she's gonna go visit
Hawkins or they are setting up for a
spinoff which would be kind of annoying
of an episode of that's the kid it's a
cool transition cool transition you
cannot do that in iMovie
maybe oh she part of or she's just a
nice sweet older lady see my friends oh
it's so close
ah Levin found a home what are you eight
this episode I have repeat this episode
at all I can see like issues okay
alright okay let me let's let's let's
let's talk about this episode this this
episode seems to be the one thing people
keep talking about a by no means hate
this I like the episode I do it feels
like it's just a different type of
eighties movie I like that touch they're
mixing it up it makes sense in tune with
where this story's been headed I don't
know if stranger things is working on a
spin-off haven't read any articles of it
or like doing a pilot within stranger
things in a way to pitch a spin-off I
have no idea it kind of is annoying if
that's the case and that thought did it
really fully enter my mind until they
all got away in the van and then once
they all got away in the van because I
thought they were all gonna die which I
was like yeah I mean I think that would
be an impactful thing in an impactful
learning lesson for 11 in some capacity
and then they didn't so made me go well
maybe they're setting up for a spinoff
or maybe they're setting up for Kay Kali
ba to come back for stranger things
season 3 I could see it going one of two
ways in terms the episode I liked
exploring this side of 11 you know this
whole season she's been trying to find
herself learn her true history I mean in
season 1 she was such a mystery and in
season 2 you're discovering her roots
and she she has to she's making a choice
on where she considers home what she had
back at Hawkins being hidden out of the
cabin you wouldn't really call that home
because she's still hiding she's still
running away
I appreciated this episode I could see
why it's upsetting because it's so
totally different than the rest of the
episodes for sure my ear is really
starting to act up right now man that's
really ringing bad I wish this
investment as I said of a nosebleed I
wish my ringing in your mentor I could
move stuff from my mind I like seeing 11
go down this darker path really using
her powers and sort of this revenge
driven type of tale and seeing her fit
in with the freaks the misfits I thought
was neat I just like seeing a different
change of tone I'm glad this is only one
episode I'm assuming this is only one
episode if this is setting up for a
spinoff I don't know how
on to spin-off RBI thing for like what
episode of cool with a whole series
dedicated to this gang of people not to
drawn to I mean you could see a
storyline where cuz these people in the
city
these cops all witnessed this crazy
thing go on and they have multiple
reports have cops witnessing things and
this time a bunch of them witnessed it
so I could see them setting up for the
mystery going on within the you know a
populated metropolis type of city I just
doesn't seem as special lures intimate
or as intriguing as what they currently
have going on with Hawkins a small town
and stranger things the idea of a
spin-off is annoying but if I just view
it as a what episode thing I'm cool with
it and as part of a Levin's journey I
haven't been able to see my other
predictions come true yet my other two
predictions are Bob's gonna die Jonathan
and Nancy will end up not being together
in the end and then my my third
prediction is because they had
everything go on with the last episode
with demo Gorgons breaking out and I'm
sure the next step it was gonna be
dedicated to the organs are attacking
and I'm sure 11 will come in like at the
last minute or something you could save
the day because they're gonna have them
deal because she's still traveling back
home so I'm sure she'll get there right
at the nick of time and I'm kind of
hoping it doesn't go down that way I'm
kind of hoping it doesn't that feels a
little predictable to me but that is my
guess anyway you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects please click that
notification but I think I'm up for one
more my ears really acting up right now
but I think I'm up for one more look
let's do this follow me at the greg alba
on instagram and twitter and please
become a patronage acted a patreon has
really helped and support this channel
in terms of youtube crazy times and plus
there's a bunch of really cool rewards
over there some cool perks we post daily
on patreon so